the Israeli military's claiming to have
shot down several anti-aircraft missiles
coming from Syria
that's after syrian state media accused
Israel of attacking targets to the west
of Damascus let's find out more from our
correspondent in Tel Aviv that's Paula
State Paula good to see what can you
tell us that about what the two sides
have had to say for themselves well the
situation has flared up quite
dramatically between Israel and Syria
and as you say both sides accusing the
other what we're hearing from the Syrian
side is that they say they activated
their ground to air defense missile
systems in response to incoming missiles
from Israel what we are hearing is that
they managed to intercept eight out of
ten rockets now syrian state media says
that they intercepted what it's calling
hostile and enemy targets that were
aiming at areas in the Damascus region
we do seem to understand that the main
target was a weapons warehouse in that
area that belonged either to Iran or
Hezbollah both of course are enemies of
the Jewish state at the same time we are
receiving reports that further air
defense systems have been deployed near
the Syrian capital for the possibility
that there could be further strikes from
the Israeli side now while all of this
was happening there were explosions that
were heard in southern Lebanon it's not
quite clear at this stage how and if
they are linked that we are seeing
hearing reports that Israel is
responsible for those we have heard from
the Israeli side the Israeli Defense
Forces Israeli army has issued a
statement in which it says it managed to
launch its air defense missile systems
and that they intercepted at least one
rocket that was fired from the Syrian
side now there were explosions that were
heard over cities in northern Israel and
the Israeli side saying however that no
one was injured and that there were no
reports to property or any kind of
damage now all of this is hot on the
heels of the American president Donald
Trump announcing that he was withdrawing
American troops from Syria you might
remember that just two days ago the
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu said that regardless of
whether or not the United States
withdraws Israel would continue to act
and act forcibly in Syria take
listen by America the decision to
withdraw two thousand US troops from
Syria will not change our consistent
policy we will continue to act against
Iran's attempts to establish a military
presence in Syria and if the need arises
we will even expand our actions there
now as a rule of thumb Israel usually
doesn't confirm or deny any kind of
activities or any kind of actions it
conducts in Syria across its northern
border but certainly for the last five
years or so it's almost an open secret
that Israel is conducting strikes
particularly against caches of weapons
equipment or facilities that belong
either to Iran or the Syrian President
Bashar al-assad now we're just receiving
information that three Syrian soldiers
have been injured we are waiting for
confirmation from the Syrian side but
that is just the latest information in
terms of any kind of casualty count
certainly tensions between Israel and
Syria are escalating mostly bring as the
latest there live from Tel Aviv Paul the
thinking
you